ils font partie intégrante du paysage
Montréal et c'est justement le problème
selon la Chambre de commerce c'est comme
si on a admis que Montréal d'entraîne de
se définir par des combats blocage
minimum c'est l'objectif que cette étude
veut aider à atteindre et on en est loin
dans le grand périmètre du centre-ville
en une année 84 % des rues ont été au
moins partiellement entre la chambre
pointe notamment le fait que plus de 9
permis d'occupation de l'espace public
sur 10 sont octroyés en plus posés la
question ça génère 24 millions de
dollars de revenus à la ville donc là
peut-être qu'on a une situation où j'ai
tendance aussi à voir ça comme un poste
de revenu au risque de compliquer la vie
dès mon réalée et des visiteurs la
beauté de la ville les trottoirs qui
sont souvent
un sac les cônes abandonné un cul-de-sac
comme celui-ci en plein centre-ville où
les abords du chantier soulèvent des
questions et ça écoute c'est c'est ça se
demandait si c'est une œuvre d'art
contemporaine s'en est rendu une blague
l'étude suggère de modifier la
réglementation et de l'adapter à la
réalité de Montréal il n'est pas normal
que dans un des quartiers les plus
denses au Québec
quand on fait un tout petit trou sur le
trottoir il nous faut une cinquantaine
de colorants absolument aucun sens il
faut vraiment falloir moderniser ses
règles là d'autant qu'un des comptes à
démontré que plus d'un cône sur 4 est
orphelins tout simplement abandonné
parmi les solutions évoquées pour
réduire l'impact des chantiers les
inscrire dans une plateforme pour les
coordonnées elle existe déjà mais la
réalité c'est que c'est une
participation facultative puis la
réalité c'est que les chiffres qu'on a
c'est que c'est 6 à 7 % des chantiers
qui sont intégrés dans l'exercice la vie
l'organisera ce printemps un sommet sur
les chantiers
s'entendre sur des normes et surtout
faire en sorte que tous les secteurs se
sentent responsabilisés pour mettre fin
à ce que l'étude appelle la frustration
perpétuelle ici Mathieu Prost
Radio-Canada